[Musique]
il était une fois on attend du passage
et si on travaille
il était une fois on n'a pas besoin de
compte c'est pour les enfants
ça tombe bien nous sommes des enfants
qui de plus gros
il n'est pas question que cet individu
échappe à ma colère des petits héros
mais plus que tu te noies je suis venu
te sauver tous les styles moi je sais
bien sûr mais sûr je sais tout alors
c'est qui qui rico
vous n'imaginez pas tout ce qu'il a pu
accomplir au bâillon à nous plutôt voir
ce que c'est parce que je suis trop
petit pour nous dire ce qu'il faut faire
générosité réponse nous la question
kylie coutu a hérité des tons de tomber
soit bien présent
on ne peut désobéir à kahrama sorcières
tu bien entendu
je suis noir sobre mais il
kirikou et les hommes et les femmes mais
surtout kirikou il est heureux dans la
pluie et le vent
il vit intensément